la fórmula para el área de un triángulo
es a igual a un medio de b por h donde a
es igual a área b es igual a la longitud
de la base y h es igual a la longitud de
la altura así es que a es igual a un
medio de b por h resuelve esta fórmula
para la altura déjame dibujar un
triángulo por aquí para que podamos
visualizar estas dimensiones aquí
tenemos un triángulo la longitud de la
base b es esta distancia de aquí y la
longitud de la altura o simplemente la
altura h es esta de aquí vamos a ponerlo
con minúscula que es como comúnmente se
escribe y nos piden resolver esta
fórmula para la altura la fórmula es
área es igual a un medio de base por
altura y nos piden resolver para h lo
que tenemos que hacer es despejar la h h
se encuentra del lado derecho vamos a
eliminar lo demás lo que podemos hacer
podríamos hacer varios paso a la vez
pero no vamos a hacerlo paso a paso
eliminemos primero este un medio
que está multiplicando a la h la mejor
manera de eliminar un medio es
multiplicarlo por su recíproco en este
caso sería 2 sobre 1 o simplemente 2
así es que hagamos eso multiplicamos por
2 multiplicamos por 2 el lado derecho y
también multiplicamos por 2 el lado
izquierdo recuerda que lo que hagas de
un lado lo tienes que hacer del otro
lado también y que nos queda bueno
hicimos esto de multiplicar por 2 para
que 2 por un medio se haga 1 por lo cual
del lado derecho nos queda tan sólo de x
h y del lado izquierdo nos queda 2 x 2
y ya casi acabamos aquí tenemos b que
multiplica h si queremos eliminar esta
vez vamos a dividir ambos lados de la
ecuación entre b dividimos entre b el
lado derecho y dividimos entre b el lado
izquierdo podemos considerar la b como
el coeficiente de la h el cual estamos
eliminando dividiendo entre b y que
tenemos del lado derecho estas veces
cancelan y nos queda tan solo h y del
lado izquierdo nos queda 2a sobre b la
ecuación resulta ahora entonces h
aquí estoy intercambiando los lados de
la ecuación h que es igual a 2a entre b
así es que
ya hemos resuelto la fórmula para la
altura y ya hemos concluido y esto puede
ser útil si alguien te proporciona una
serie de áreas y de bases y te pide que
encuentres las alturas para esos datos
las alturas de estos triángulos